il ya des traces 1 j'espérais vraiment à
ce qu'il est je pense le fait ça dans
son but par un objet par quelque chose
qui dépasse le fait qu'en l'état vient
soutenir les éleveurs cet après-midi à
saint-joseph
le ministre de l'agriculture julien de
normandie a insisté sur la mobilisation
active du gouvernement plus d'une
douzaine de chevaux ont été victimes de
violentes agressions ces dernières
semaines dans l'hexagone il ya des
services techniques comme les services
du ministère de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation qui apporte ici ou là des
expertises je pense notamment à
l'ensemble des services vétérinaires le
président des vétérinaires
ma compagne est également aujourd'hui
pour pouvoir ici ou là donner des
expertises et donner des informations
supplémentaires bref c'est une
mobilisation générale
ce centre n'a pas été choisi par hasard
dans la nuit du 25 au 26 août
une jument a été retrouvé dans son box
avec une oreille coupée pour le
propriétaire ça ne peut pas être un
accident il ya forcément eu agression
les éleveurs touchés se sont démunis la
chose qui fait vraiment plaisir c'est
tout ce déplacement et tous toute cette
mobilisation et on s'en prennent là on
se sent vraiment passé comme ça c'est ça
fait beaucoup
ça rassure beaucoup voilà quand on m'a
pire pour me dire que
ministre venait ça ça fait quelque chose
pas parce que ça vient chez moi et peu
mais c'est pour la filière je pars sans
soutenu pour le moment les enquêteurs
préfèrent rester discrets sur leur
avancée si les coupables de ces actes de
cruauté envers les animaux sont
retrouvés il encourt jusqu'à deux ans
d'emprisonnement et 30 mille euros
d'amendé